il ya de monde c'est squeeze et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour un petit
gameplay
bon il y en a pas des masses sur youtube
il faut bien le dire sur medal of honor
way far far side où commence très bien
donc pour ceux qui ne savent pas donc
bon là en début de vidéo vous venez de
voir la petite bande annonce entre
guillemets de la vidéo que j'ai sorti
juste avant celle qui regarde l'heure
actuelle c'est à dire celle ci en fait
lié à inviter beaucoup de youtube heures
dans ses locaux à lyon pour tester le
nouveau medal of honor est un jeu juste
baisser un petit peu son du jeu voilà
pour tester le nouveau medal of honor
donc wait facteurs qui sort warfighter
proches du malade est un qui sort donc
il me semble en novembre donc on a tous
été invités on devait être vain donc
avec why avec hendrix neuf mois creux
xing la rue jojo soonnight hausse et les
bornes
bon bref et cetera de façon je crois que
benoît l'a déjà dit ça dans sa vidéo est
d'ailleurs on va tous hier environ à peu
près les mêmes choses dans notre vidéo
enfin si ce n'est que deux impressions
ne seront pas les mêmes évidemment donc
qui coûtait bon medal of honor celui de
l'année dernière il faut bien le dire
c'était un espèce de brouillon pour
tester un gameplay
bon en gros il s'entraînait à essayer de
développer quelque chose pour au final
de sortir dans battlefield 3 et tu vas
te le fil 3 déchire tout ce qu'a été le
cas d'ailleurs il faut bien dire
battlefield 3 a très très bien
fonctionné bon là je m'attendais à
quelque chose du genre est en fait il
faut le dire ce medal of honor à son
style particulier si on peut dire c'est
à dire que bon ce n'est pas du call of
duty ce n'est pas du battlefield 3 c'est
un espèce de mix entre les deux c'est à
dire que bon bon dans call of duty voilà
on voit très souvent les ennemis toutes
les dix secondes voir moi-même alors
dans battlefield 3 on en voit vraiment
pas énormément surtout sur dernier dlc
qui l'ont fait d'ailleurs à mort et de
kiel où les mâles sont titanesques bon
là c'est un espèce de une variante entre
les deux qui fait que bon il ya le style
battlefield 3 mais il ya quand même
quelque part cet aspect on voit bien
plus les ennemis et ce à un peu plus
rapproché dans le combat que dans
battlefield 3 donc là on joue un mode de
jeu hotspot le camp français je sais
même plus ce que ça veut dire excuse
evra enfin bon en gros c'est un mode de
juges vous expliquer ce que c'est ou en
fait il ya un relais donc un rôle et
qu'ils faisaient là vous voyez les là
bas à droite il ya un temps donc donc à
une équipe qui défend leur laine équipe
qui doit l'attaqué et il ya un temps et
donc les attaquants un certain temps
pour aller justement péter ce relais bon
généralement nous on s'est un peu fait
trouer faut bien dire allez je suis dans
l'équipe qui s'est fait trouer pendant
toute la lan
bon là en attaque et c'était une de nos
premières parties en attaque donc banda
d'un petit peu de mal faut bien le dire
enfin bon c'est un mode de jeu assez
sympa et lorsque des carbo les explose
eh ben il ya les quatre autres rôles est
disponible sur la map qui s'affiche
et puis le relais où il ya le plus
d'attaquants aux alentours c'est celui
qui s'activent et c'est celui donc qui
va falloir prendre voilà vous avez
compris enfin bon nombre d'heures ce
medal of honor me direz vous mais qu'est
ce qui change par rapport à battlefield
3 parce que bon au niveau des graphismes
c'est le même moteur graphique se fera
au frostbite 2 bon là c'est une version
alpha
donc vous vous verrez pas vraiment les
graphistes de battlefield 3 c'est un
petit peu moins cool enfin dans le sens
où c'est une alfa non qu'ils exploitent
pas les graphismes maximum c'est plutôt
quelque chose pour corriger tous les
bugs les bugs de collisions enfin et
c'est tout ça les glitchs etc
et puis bah écoute et au final il ya
quand même un style particulier dans le
sens où déjà premièrement donc la
personne dont qui travaillent chez nous
explique et tué la particularité de ce
medal of honor que c'est ce sont des
escouades de 2 dans battlefield 3 en
faire des squats de 3 hélas non là ce
sont des escouades de 2 c'est à dire
qu'en fait vous allez jouer avec votre
coéquipier pour moi dans cette équipe
j'étais avec dix guides x de masse quad
bon escouade de bras cassés mondiale
gère donc il est juste là on voit offert
en fait à travers les murs etc
pour bien pouvoir le situer et
honnêtement c'est un style de jeu
particulier et c'est très prenant c'est
à dire que vous êtes à fond dedans bien
plus que dans une escouade à quatre ou
six généralement bon quand vous jeu
juste avec un ami on a toujours ou deux
dans votre choix tu ne sais pas pourquoi
tu tombes d'une squad où il y en a deux
qui sont nuls
bon ça je pars des saveurs blindés vous
êtes forcé à avoir des personnes dans
votre squad
honnêtement c'est un petit peu chiant
alors que là vous êtes forcément
uniquement avec la personne bas que vous
souhaitez donc je le logiquement qu'on
jouait qu'avec meilleur ami et c'était
avant la soirée - choix et enfin voilà
ça c'est cool
et puis du coup il ya pas mal de points
bonus liés à cette escouade de 2 donc
vous faire des actions en groupe par
exemple neutraliser un ennemi ensemble
quand votre quand la personne à votre
squad n'a plus beaucoup de vies au plus
beaucoup de balles vous courez vers
l'est ou fait j'aurais pu vous appuyez
sur a ou sur bon sur xbox ps3 doit être
une autre touche évidemment et vous le
soigner voulu donner des munitions donc
ça c'est vraiment cool bon ah là là non
on tournait souvent c'est venu sur le
vélo ça va mais honnêtement et c'est un
truc vraiment cool et ça entraîne le
gameplay en équipe et même pas forcément
juste pour avoir des points mais parce
qu'on ait une envie de gagner on a une
espèce de rage mais là on est deux vases
il faut qu'on gère bon là on essaie de
les prendre en bike avec big l'x un bon
c'est un peu fait trouer faut bien le
dire vous et loire qu'il ya quand même
des petites actions qui sont jolies et
vos désert bien évidemment on peut les
personnaliser donc comme dans
battlefield viseur laser et cetera et
cetera et c'est bon là en l'occurrence
on était tous niveaux 1 donc on n'avait
pas grand chose à personnaliser
par contre au niveau des classes en
revanche j'ai un changement par rapport
à battlefield donc dans battlefield
avait quatre classes le medic le assaut
le l'ingénieur et puis le sniper voilà
dans ce medal of honor vous avez six
classes et vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de ressusciter un vos alliés
comme dans battlefield 3 c'est
d'ailleurs moi j'ai eu au début j'étais
layoule du sud le butin est en fait ça
sert à rien on peut pas ressusciter ces
années on peut juste a ordonné de
donc comme je dis précédemment enfin à
la personne de sa squad uniquement donc
vraiment jouer en binôme donc au niveau
des six classes liga si je me souviens
venir bail
évidemment il ya le sniper ya le gros
avec sa famille trio ce qu'ils peuvent
et il ya aussi la sau donc celui que
j'ai là c'est la classe tout à droite il
me semble bon alors en gros entre sept
places et deux autres je crois qu'après
grand chose qui change en fait ya trois
classes qui se contentent fortement
c'est juste assauts une classe nay peur
une classe gros bourrin et enfin bref
faut que je regarde et je sais qu'au
niveau des classes si on a si c'est
qu'en fait ce qui change surtout c'est
l'accessoire c'est à dire que vous avez
une classe vous avez un lance-grenade
une classe vous avez un espèce de
capteurs quand vous appuyez sur la
touche
voilà up l'inversé de la vie ou quand
vous appuyez sur la touche pendant deux
secondes c'est un petit peu la splinter
cell le capteur là qui est bon qui me
fait voir à travers les mieux en bas là
c'est un petit peu le même principe
vous voyez les ennemis des alentours
pendant une seconde même pas vous voyez
juste où ils sont placés jeudi une image
et puis après vous avez une autre classe
je sais plus ce que c'est l'accessoire
ah oui voilà c'est des balles qui font
plus mal bon là malheureusement j'ai
préféré jouer avec l'accessoire on
voyait très remuant mais si je n'ai pas
beaucoup utilisé c'est vrai mais en tout
cas ouais c'est du coup c'est pas mal on
peut vraiment choisir sa classe en
fonction des difficultés de l'équipe et
de nos envies à nous si on préfère avoir
des balles qui font mal ou si on veut
céder de l'espèce de 2,2 wallach un
petit job en seconde on va dire ensuite
donc bien évidemment aulas vous voyez le
temps qu'il reste aux attaquants pour
faire péter objectif les killstreaks
donc là je vais utiliser un kit strict
donc ça s'obtient par l on sent une
série d'éliminations bon une série de
points plutôt en soignant ses alliés ou
en tuant des ennemis ou etc
donc je vais [ __ ] tout métier strict
littéralement là dessus pour ici protégé
à fond objectif vous voyez je lance des
grenades je lance tout genre enfin bref
et ça a plutôt bien marché d'ailleurs
faut bien le dire
donc bon je pense qu'on va réussir voilà
le relais à péter vos voyages du coup
j'ai re débloquer un mortier je le remet
instantanément de succès bien la merde
et qu'en face ils zappent franchement
faut bien le dire
ils défendent et bien lieu
pro b f là dans l'haleine c'était super
balèze à quelqu'un de la team aaa bon
jouer dans notre équipe mais en face il
y avait ni baisse les gens des autres
personnes qui étaient franchement balèze
enfin bon voilà donc c'est tout pour les
killstreaks sinon une autre petite
particularité quand la personne de votre
binôme se fait tuer ben par un ennemi
tout simplement ils préfèrent tuer pas
par une banane nan shan zhai witsel
venant il se fait tuer par l'ennemi
cet ennemi qui vous tue voilà par
exemple âge vient de mourir à apparaît
en rouge donc et si la personne de votre
binôme tu l'ennemi liquide qui est bon
coton contours et en rouge s'ils veulent
à la personne qui est à bout c'est à
dire qu'il serait tué sept personnes qui
m'a tuer quelques contours en rouge et
ben j'aurais pu spawn instantanément
voilà donc c'est ça c'est un truc plutôt
cool voilà là encore une fois on voit
les l'entourant rouge vous voilà donc la
digue dit je crois qu'il a eu et du coup
voilà j'ai spawn instantanément fou
quelle belle illustration maintenant
objets emballer ce qui arrive donc ça
c'est un truc plutôt cool bon du coup
après forcément on a tendance à faire et
à vouloir le tuer tout de suite pour que
notre allié à se pose mais je préfère ça
parce que on jette dans des pièges assez
facilement qu'on fait ça c'est un peu
bête mais sinon voilà ce système là et
quand même assez cool donc au niveau des
classes on peut aussi avoir bon là en
l'occurrence on pouvait pas changer
d'armes directement comme dans le menu
de bf3 vous pouvez prendre la main que
voulait juste pas n'importe quelle arme
vous allez menu toutes les armes là en
l'occurrence on pouvait pas on pouvait
simplement changer de pays
il n'y a pas la france honnêtement il
n'ya pas la france ou alors j'ai pas
trouvé pourtant je crois que j'ai fait
toutes les classes ne semble pas qui à
la france alors que pourtant c'est une
des forces européennes les plus balèze
donc je suis un petit peu dégoûté enfin
bon c'est pas grave on va pas s'arrêter
à cette taille là on va pas acheter le
jeu ou pas juste parce que il ya la
france nous en tout cas je sais qu'il ya
bon forcément les américains au les
grands américains forts et qui qui font
régner la paix dans le mans comme dans
chaque jeu où julie bec philibert ya les
américains devaient avoir les rues je
croyais les polonais me semble bon je
suis plus fort bref il ya différents
pays et en fonction du pays comprend
larmes change
bon là par exemple je crois que tu es
américain et si on changeait de pied on
a vu une mp7 est par contre moi ce que
j'ai noté ce qui m'a fortement fichier 1
je vais bien je vais vous dire c'est un
des trucs c'est le truc en fait il m'a
bien fait chier c'est la différence de
puissance entre les armes c'est à dire
qu'avec cette arme blague
il faut environ calais la moitié d'un
chargeur dans l'ennemi même en visant
dans le torse pour qu'ils meurent alors
qu'avec une mp7 vous mettez 85 ban six
balles et l'ennemi est mort donc bon
j'ai un peu la haine parce que j'ai
découvert la mp 7 à la toute fin de la
journée on va dire de partir avant la
fin j'ai découvert le mp7 qu'on pouvait
changer de pays etc
puisque je n'ai pas trouvé comment on
faisait je pensais que la fonction
n'avait pas été débloquée donc j'étais
un peu deg
et là je fais exprès de mettre un coup
de couteau pour vous dire que on n'a pas
un peu tôt mais on a une tomahawk dans
la main et du coup c'était plutôt drôle
c'est ce que vous avez vu dans la vidéo
pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu un cliquez
sur notation va à gauche dans la vidéo
irl à étauliers youtuber et diane qui
faisait pas chez hachette pochette match
est parce qu on arrive en fait et en
deux coups de machettes ont tué un
ennemi puis il les enchaîne super
rapidement donc moi j'avais fait mon
four battant d'ailleurs une porte parce
que j'ai plus de balles et ses jobs ait
neuf qui arrivait j'ai fait machette
machette et je n'ai eu qu'un bref
c'était bien drôle tuer une âme c est
franchement c'était la première lan de
ma vie et c'est franchement sympa
puisque quand vous mourrez vous levez la
tête avec un les sourcils froncés vous
faites au physique m'a tuer rats et là
je vois benoît qui me regarde je reviens
parce que j'étais mort de rire parce que
j'aime j'avais joué que comme un [ __ ]
en faut bien dire le mec qu'attendre une
porte que löw tente pour lui qui fêtait
sa abominable mais c'était tellement
drôle parce qu'en plus vous êtes sur
l'ennemi puis tu m'as promis
marqueurs n'ya pas d'animation pour le
couteau comme dans basel iii donc tu
fais machette machette
c'est super drôle enfin bon on n'avait
pas repoussé l'atome a hobo concours et
comme des poulets les uns après les
autres
c'était vraiment fun y avait vraiment
une très bonne ambiance est l'âme enfin
bon voilà tout ça pour dire que ce n'est
pas un couteau mais le tomahawk dans ce
medal of honor donc voilà au niveau des
armes le déséquilibre que je trouvais
voilà ça m'a un peu blasé je dois bien
vous dire devoir vider la moitié d'un
chargeur sur un ennemi pour qu'il meure
je trouve ça un petit peu abusé sachant
que dans la vraie vie en une ou deux
balles l'aimiez ko par terre bon après
ça dépend si c'est une balle dans leurs
feuilles
la chaîne jambes mais bon voilà bon là
il est mis de lui manquer de la vie mais
honnêtement je peux vous dire c'est
plutôt énervant bon je pense qu'ils vont
rééquilibrer tout ça de toute manière
c'est qu'une bêta même l'alpha ce n'est
même pas la beta c'est l'alpha donc faut
vraiment pas s'y fier et d'ailleurs pour
ceux qui seraient intéressés y aura une
bêta
début octobre il me semble sur xbox pas
sur pc dommage mais sur xbox y aura une
petite bêta du jeu donc vous pourrez
vous faire une idée vous même du jeu
mais en tout cas nous je pense que dans
l'ensemble on a bien apprécié à parts
égales par tirage va alors honnêtement
mais vous auriez vu ça mais c'est aimer
à mourir de rire
ils apparaissaient entre tous vos
esprits des débats les moret et à la fin
ils campaient au spawn arrive son sniper
allongé sur une pierre en déployant le
vieil homme comme un vieux gars c'était
franchement marrant il faisait bien rien
mais où est la bonne humeur était là et
puis honnêtement bas - medal of honor ce
que j'en pense
ça a l'air d'être une bonne alternative
entre call of et battlefield 3 et puis
bon c'est un bon jeu en attendant
battlefield kate on va dire et il me
semble qu'il y aura un dlc gratuit avec
deux mâts pour ceux qui ont précommandé
le jeu et puis voilà bon ce sera pas
j'ai aussi complet que battlefield 3
c'est clair mais ce sera une bonne
alternative est un bon moyen de se
changer les idées entre un call of et un
petit battle filtre voilà moi en tout
cas là la partie va se terminer a
accidentellement alors qu'on devait
attaquer le relais parce que ça crache
et une semble enfin le serveur avait
craché de qu'il a dû redémarrer dans
tous les cas je trouve que c'est une
belle alternative entre battlefield 3 et
call of personnellement je me le
prendrais pour le fun enfin j'aime bien
j'ai bien aimé le gameplay puis ce
système de binômes m'intéresse tout
simplement enfin bon faites vous votre
opinion par vous même regardé les vidéos
des différents youtuber qui étaient
présents night of the west of roxy etc
et puis faites vous une opinion du jeu
et vous verrez vous ferez à l'idée vous
ferez une idée du jeu plutôt par vous
excusez moi et puis voilà en tout cas on
se retrouve partout dans une prochaine
vidéo vous pouvez regarder la vidéo est
réel que j'ai fait avec tous les youtube
heure là vous voyez ça veut dire je
courais dans le vide
regardez les